hey this is dr. John dallona with Ramsey
Network it's awesome to talk to you
today number one thank you to everybody
who's subscribing to these videos man
the channel is just getting bigger and
bigger and thank you for sending it to
your friends and your family especially
those are talking about racism talking
about anxiety talking about all the
stuff going on in the world today
I appreciate you tuning in and listening
and I'm gonna continue to put out videos
continue to walk alongside you guys
thank you so much today we can take
emails about anxiety about the things
that are troubling each one of you and
then we're gonna get directly into it so
here we go first email up today Scott
asks hey John how's it going good pretty
good doing well I work for my family
business
and during this end-of-the-world phase I
have been working like a madman to make
sure that we stay on our price targets
through this year we were deemed an
essential business but most of our
employees left on their own will we now
have people who have replaced everyone
who left but I kept my foot on the pedal
I was working 70 to 75 hours a week and
last Friday I mentally broke down at
work the family has decided it's in my
best interest to pull back because that
isn't in my blood to do what the rest of
the family does I feel guilty about
leaving them with more of a burden my
question is do you think it's a valid
reason to feel guilty about all of this
at home I have a wife and a
six-month-old baby and I'm just torn up
about what has happened dude Scott thank
you for the email a couple of things
here I want to talk through number one
it's not the end of the world times just
not OK if you go back and read some
literature from a hundred years ago when
the flu pandemic if you read some
literature before that every hundred
years every 50 years every 20 years
there's a big thing a big cage rattling
moment when my dad was a kid it was
coming out of World War two and there
were nuclear weapons pointed at the
United States sitting there in Cuba and
everyone thought the time had come that
this was it my dad had to do nuclear
weapon drills at school as an elementary
school student whoa right so yeah we're
in a mess
millions and millions of people are out
of jobs the United States and the
Western world is having this massive
Awakening
about this tension between who we say we
are and the way we've lived it's very
similar to a lot of us who have said I'm
this kind of person I'm that kind of
person and then we look in the mirror
the last few months we've been stuck at
home and realized no we're not I'm not
as tough as I thought I was I'm not as
strong as I thought I was I am NOT as
ethical as I thought it was I'm not a
great husband like I thought it was all
of us are coming to this this reckoning
and it's really uncomfortable and it's
messy and it's scary so it's not in
thymes and I want everyone to always be
thinking about the light at the other
end of this and what you can do to be
walking towards a light not just
prepping for end times okay those are
for a any specials and for weird
internet chat channels okay so the
second thing here is this good for you
and good for you Scott the world got
crazy and you looked around and said
I've got a family to take care of I've
got a young baby I've got a wife I've
got a family business I've got employees
that work for me I've got a community to
serve and you hit the gas you saw fear
you felt anxiety you got nervous and
then you went in and you were brave and
so I want to applaud you for that I
appreciate your work in your local
community and on behalf of your family
but then comes the other side of that
right you worked 70 75 hours a week you
lost all your employees you hired new
employees back and you kept driving and
driving and driving and then you crashed
so you remember in our anxiety video
your kitchen was on fire right you had
smoke coming out of the oven
you had your countertop was on fire the
roof was on fire everything's burning
and burning and you were running around
making it happen
you kept cooking the meals you kept
making sure people were fed and that
works for a minute if you look around at
the anxiety and the depression and the
ADHD statistics millions and millions
and millions of millions it's almost a
vertical trend line if you look at the
diseases of despair people are dying
from heart disease and liver disease and
addictions and suicides that's this the
United States the Western world our
neighborhoods have been working like
crazy for the last
five 10 20 50 years and we're all at a
breaking point all of our alarms are
going off and we're exhausted and that's
where you found yourself you broke and
we all do you were blessed with a
community with a family who loves you
and said in these moments when you can't
take care of you
we're gonna ask you to step back put
your oxygen mask on get some rest
love that little baby love your wife
recharge and then we'll get you back in
the game it's what a good quarter man
does for a fighter right the quarter man
is there to protect the fighter when the
fighter is just in it and they can't
protect themselves so good for your
family for taking care of you for taking
care of the business at some point your
breakdown breaks down the whole business
right so the question you ask directly
as this is this a valid reason for you
to feel guilty I'm gonna say no you
shouldn't feel guilty but I'm also gonna
tell you feeling guilty is normal I'm
not gonna take that from you okay so are
you feeling guilty yeah you are you
feeling like I should be at work I
should be helping out I should be doing
these things that's natural you're a
fighter you're a good dad you're a good
husband and you're a good businessman so
a better way to frame it is it's normal
to feel guilty but as I just said should
you know know you're a fireman you ran
into a burning building you put it out
your adrenaline was running your
cortisol was running you weren't
sleeping you were making it happen and
now it's time to rest now it's time to
rest and now it's time to reconnect with
your baby girl it's time to reconnect
with your beautiful wife it's time to
have breakfast with your family it's
time to have lots of skin-on-skin
contact time look people in the eye set
out in the front yard go for walks
without shoes on it's time to reconnect
and let your other family members pick
up the slack for a while so Scott you
didn't ask me but I'm gonna tell you
what I think you should do number one
like I just said reconnect connect with
your baby girl your wife your family
number two I want you to get one or two
guys in your neighborhood in your
community whether it's from your
Church folks that used to work with
local suppliers that you're buddies with
and I want you to go for coffee with
those dudes go have a beer with those
guys and I want you to tell them hey I
broke man I want you to be honest with
them like you were with me and what
you'll probably find is they'll look at
you
uncomfortably for a second and they'll
say man me too and then you're going to
have a connection there that goes deep
and that will help feed you over the
next few months and few years number
three I want you to sit down with your
wife and I want you to detail out a
reentry plan what does the rest look
like for you what is getting whole look
like for you and what is going back to
work look like because you know 70 to 75
hours of just redlining it it's not
gonna be sustainable long term so what
does re-entry look like does it look
like a couple of 50-hour weeks or some
40-hour weeks does it look like hiring
somebody else to take some the
administrative load off of you does it
look like she's gonna text you every day
at 4:30 and say you got 30 minutes left
and then I want you to come home
whatever it looks like does it look like
partnering up with her on how you can
better help at home and you're gonna
find someone else to pick up your slack
at work whatever it looks like get with
your wife and create a detailed plan of
what reentry looks like Scott you're a
good man I'm proud of you for doing the
hard work for being brave and now it's
time to do the most brave thing which is
to be vulnerable and whole at home to
love your wife to be a good partner love
your baby girl be a good dad and then to
draw up new plans for what tomorrow's
gonna look like go get them Scott this
is dr. John Delaney with Ramsey Network
take care
subscribe tell your friends to email me
at ask John at Ramsey solutions comm and
I'll see you soon
take care